what opportunities are there for teens I
got a great question for one of my
YouTube viewers love you guys
den who wrote in basically saying what
opportunities are available for teens
often when you're starting to learn a
skill that everything's really expensive
starting materials how do I get started
how do I participate so then this is a
great question you have to start
connecting with people and start
exposing your passion let people know
what you're excited about let them know
what you need to get started and people
will find ways to help you okay here's a
couple examples Steve Jobs okay we all
know Steve Jobs when he was 13 years old
he wanted to build his own little
machine but he needed a part from
Hewlett Packard so he called up Hewlett
Packard and said I'm 13 years old I want
to build this but I need one of your
parts they not only gave him the part
but they gave him a summer job as well
working at Hewlett Packard I was
watching Dragons Den last night Jonathan
is like sharks tank but it's for
Canadians is also in Britain and there
was this 14 year old kid who part-time
after school was doing day trading he
built his own formula for what makes a
successful day trader and he was day
trading currencies and stocks and he
just had everybody blown away with his
passion and the small results that he
was already getting and he got them to
invest fifty thousand dollars in the
business and to give him a summer job as
well you have to expose your passion and
start talking to people they'll find
ways to help you whatever you're
interested in doing if you can't do it
yourself
if you can't do it with it with your own
computer your own programs reach out to
a company who's doing it already who's
great at what they do and find a way to
get involved
show them how excited you are about this
and you're willing to do anything to
learn people love that passion and they
don't see it enough in young people and
if you're a young teen and you're just
getting started people will want to help
you because rarely do you see that kind
of excitement
I had my first business my first
business was really selling baseball
cards I was 12 13 years old and I would
make more money i garage sales selling
my baseball cards than everybody else
who was out there selling their their
tables and expensive furniture and all
these high ticket items I made more
selling my baseball cards as a 12 and 13
year old kid when I was 19 I wanted to
start a business I didn't know what I
wanted to do and I hooked up with two
people who were in biotech software who
at my University and I didn't know
anything about software I wanted to be
the business man behind it and I helped
them build this company up and
eventually sold it we got acquired by
public company and so just get started
don't hold yourself back thinking I'm
too young I can never do this a lot of
successful entrepreneurs started when
they were really young and they just had
they had the guts to go out and start
asking people for help so whatever you
want to get into start asking for help
start exposing your ideas to them start
showing them how excited and energetic
you are about something and they will
give you opportunities reach out belief
those are watching like the video please
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes you want to do more let me know
what you think you have a comment you
have something to say you have a
question leave it in the comments below
I'll make a video response and if you
like the channel please subscribe so you
can get more videos coming soon thank
you so much and I'll see you soon
you